what did you feel when Iranian blundered
his Queen
happy what do you do to impress and
surprise your opponents
well I mean it's just small small tweaks
and known ideas uh or chest wise chest
wise ah other one it's not like or
something to surprise their opponent
the opening Choice suggests that perhaps
also a German is involved on the team
you may speculate as much as you want I
think that's half the fun of being a
journalist at the world championship
match Michael you have quite a lot of
chairs in your room we noticed uh you're
not gonna sell it in them on eBay for
your fans at all or give them any aways
prizes
no uh whenever I am on the rare
occasions that I I do streams I need the
chairs for the idiots in the back